we see the Enterprise f for a couple of
beautiful seconds in the beginning of
Picard series 3. but we may never see
her again
why
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so I have done a couple of videos
talking about the card series three I
have talked about how I am quite
concerned about Picard Series 3 but
the closer we get to the release of this
season the more excited I am getting and
the more confident I am that we're
actually going to be getting a brilliant
series of Star Trek a season of Star
Trek that these characters actually
deserve and I'm quite excited but
something I came across today
disappointed me somewhat it seems that
the Enterprise F The Odyssey class
starship that we've been dying to see on
Canon actually on screen for so long
might be the only Voyage of this vessel
we get to see now we already know from
the trailer we get to see this beautiful
shot of the Odyssey flying by with a
small fertility of all the vessels but
information released through starfleet's
Instagram account today and the Titans
data logs all promotional information
building up towards the series we found
that actually the Enterprise f
was on its way to be decommissioned yes
that's right the first time we get to
see this vessel will also be its last
so what can I hear you cry what how can
this be the case how can this be true
God why I mean Terry would tell us what
the hell are you thinking what are you
doing to this why are you doing this to
us I mean Terry metallis the showrunner
of this series what the hell are you
thinking what are you doing to us
right so let's just go through quickly
what we know about first of all the
Enterprise E and then the Enterprise F
so from the end of Prodigy we actually
got to see the end of the Enterprise E
now this wasn't confirmed but the
Enterprise was in the fleet that came to
Aid the protostar at the end of Prodigy
if you haven't seen it there's a big
battle basically there's this thing this
living construct that can infect
computer systems and it infects the
computer systems of any Starship it
comes in touch within those system the
ships basically just turned on each
other we actually see lots of Starfleet
vessels getting blown to pieces one of
them being the Enterprise E now the last
we see of her she is heavily damaged
she's completely blacked out there's no
lights anywhere and there's several very
large gashes in the hull but she's still
mostly intact
so he didn't actually know was this the
end of the Enterprise E well it seems
like it was that attack happened in
2384. according to these data logs
thanks to the Titan the Enterprise F was
then launched in 2386 only two years
later so I think from that we can assume
that the Enterprise was probably
unsalvageable we are making an
assumption there but it would make sense
and then they built the new Enterprise
the Enterprise F The Odyssey class
however then only survived 15 years now
I think it's fair to say stuffly vessels
don't last the way they used to if you
look at sort of the Excelsior class or
Constitution class those vessels were in
operation with Starfleet at the front
line for 50 60 70 80 years they would
just constantly got refit they have a
good space frame and then you can just
swap out technology as you need to
upgrade it now don't get me wrong an
Excelsior class vessel probably is not
going to be in the front line the same
way a sovereign would but we actually
saw repeatedly that Excelsior class like
during the Dominion War Etc were in the
front line several Excelsior class
vessels are actually destroyed during
the Battle of War 359 but obviously
after the Borg and after the um Dominion
conflict we can assume that starfully
would have been heavily upgraded it's
considering its losses but what do we
actually know about why the Federation F
was being decommissioned well all we
know is that its critical systems were
very heavily damaged or compromised
during something called the mafette
Gambit now this is quite a lot of detail
about why the federation's flagship was
being decommissioned so it makes me
wonder
is there a long-term plan is this really
going to be the last we see of the
Enterprise F or actually is there a plan
to fill in some of these Missing Years
and maybe get to see some details of the
Voyages of the Enterprise F now that
would be amazing but I got a couple of
points I'd like to make I'm sick to
death of Star Trek jumping through time
frames if this is going to be another
prequel a series or something based
before Picard season three I'm going to
be really irritated we've already got
Prodigy and lower decks which roughly
are in the same time period we've then
got Picard which is 20 years ahead in
the now the 1401 and we have strange new
worlds and then we also have discovery
which is set away in the future so we've
already got four time frames on the go
at the moment the over five series
we don't need anymore it's confusing
enough as it is
maybe they would do this through comic
books maybe we get to see the Enterprise
in that format well that would be for me
a shame the Enterprise is at the end of
the day the vessel within the Federation
that we are most interested in we like
to know what's going on with her so it
would be a shame if that was the only
way we got to see it
obviously she's in the games and there's
a rich history Blair but that is a beta
Canon to say the least
so how else could they do it well maybe
we'll get to see her in the Animated
Series maybe we'll get to see her in
prodigy
again that would be a little bit of a
shame but actually the battle sequences
at the end of series one of Prodigy were
amazing if you are the sort of Star Trek
fan like me that enjoys a space battle
you've really got to watch the end of
Prodigy it's great so if they did it
that way I could live with it but again
I would be disappointed now don't get me
wrong I don't think we're ever actually
going to see another Star Trek series
based aboard an Enterprise we should we
want it we'd love it but I don't think
we're going to get to see that aboard
the Enterprise f
is there though another possibility
because obviously there's a lot more
letters in the alphabet could we
actually see Star Trek the next next
Generation where we see the Voyages of
the Starship Enterprise G well that
would be pretty cool and we'd get to see
a new Enterprise as well I mean seeing
the Odyssey has been very cool because
they brought that from the game but we
knew what to expect the Enterprise G we
have no idea so that would be kind of
cool but do I actually think that's the
plan probably not so let's see what
happens in the coming years because we
are expecting a new series to be
announced following Picard Series 3
ending
what could that Series be we just don't
know some interesting time ahead some
big questions thrown out there again by
Picard season three and a little bit of
a disappointment already but hey we got
to see the Enterprise that's very very
cool if it's the only time we get to see
you that will be a massive
disappointment but let's cross our
fingers let's hope the best and let's
hope that this isn't the final voyage of
the Enterprise but guys get in the
comments to tell me what you think is
this Cameo of the Odyssey Enterprise a
massive disappointment or are you just
glad to see her on screen and what do
you think is next for the Voyages of the
Starship Enterprise do you think we'll
get to see the G in some future
incarnation of Star Trek I'd love to
know exactly what you think if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
but the Bell notification really helps
us out and if you want to become a fully
fledged side Trekker please consider
hitting the join button there's also
links to all of our other things
including Discord talk blah blah blah in
the description
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]